when Lu Kang delivers his fatal blow he
summons a dragon that bites down on his
opponent this is a call back to his
animality in Mortal Kombat 3 a nice
touch considering animality 's haven't
appeared in the series says 1996 is
Mortal Kombat trilogy Mortal Kombat
loves to reference itself an MK 11 is no
exception I mean let's be honest this
whole game is a love letter to the
series and it's use of time travel
allows for some really fun nods we're
gonna focus on what we think are the
coolest funniest and strangest
references we found so far undoubtedly
there will be ones we've missed so
please post those in the comments below
perhaps when the most exciting things
about Mortal Kombat 11 is its love for
the 1995 cult classic movie Shang soon's
voice actor and face model is Kari
Hiroyuki Takaya who portrayed the
sorcerer in the original film Shang soon
is a planned DLC character but he still
makes an appearance in the game script
the Crypt is a fully realized version of
Shang soon's Island that you can walk
around and explore the whole thing is a
callback to the original game you'll
visit classic Mortal Kombat stages such
as the pit and the warrior shrine but
there are also locations taken from the
film such as Goro as a dining hall at
the head of the table is the skeletal
remains of Kano who in the film spends
his time there stuffing his face you
know one-on-one man-to-man hand to hand
the Crypt is filled with countless items
to collect many of which belong to
Mortal Kombat characters you'll also
collect a bucket of water known as
element that brings life a seemingly
out-of-place item at first this is
actually another nod to the film where
Liu Kang uses a bucket of water to
defeat sub-zero
another movie reference comes from mr.
Hollywood himself one of Johnny cages
cosmetics is a pair of $500 sunglasses
the same pair Johnny wore in the film
finally the tournament stage music is a
remix of the iconic Mortal Kombat movie
theme
[Music]
this tournament stage is fantastic by
the way
the arcade machines in the background
are for Mortal Kombat X Deadly Alliance
Shaolin monks and deception it's also
the only stage where the easter-egg
toastie will appear
[Applause]
[Music]
the ROM has become known recently for
its character intro dialogues where
hundreds of lines of dialogue have been
recorded so that every character has
something special to say to each other
many of these lines touch on established
character relationships and past story
events but there are also some clever
references Raiden and Liu Kang play on
the names of the 3d era of Mortal Kombat
games Deadly Alliance deception and
Armageddon
are we the deadly Alliance that is
cronic as deception or a recipe for
Armageddon if you do a noob saibot Muir
match you might get this Harry Potter
joke Raiden and sub-zero appear as DLC
guest fighters in nether realms last
game injustice - and they will
acknowledge it in their intro I dreamt
of a strange and unjust world with a
dark night at a caped wonder how could
you know my dream when fighting gear is
Johnny Cage can reference the famous
tears in rain monologue delivered by Roy
batty at the end of Blade Runner I have
seen things you
believe attack ships on fire off the
shoulder of Orion
time to die love Disney's frozen of
course you do oh honey let me help you
storm rage on time to test my limits and
break through
Erin blacks default intro has him
dropping a sack with a severed head in
it that head belongs to hasu how a
member of the Red Dragon Clan who first
appeared in mortal kombat Deadly
Alliance Cassie cage is one of the more
tongue-in-cheek characters and her
intros reflect that like the one where
she texts people before the fight one of
the people she text is Ronda Rousey the
WWE star who voices Sonya Blade in MK 11
she'll also get a text from Mortal
Kombat co-creator Ed Boon Cassy will
also make a Samurai Jack joke which just
makes me very happy in Cassie's intro
where she's holding a drink the logo on
the cup says a mocap mocha this is a
reference to mocap the hidden character
in Deadly Alliance who is literally a
man in a mocap suit my personal favorite
reference is a bit subtle and comes from
the story mode chapter 3 is called
Shaolin monks and has you playing as
both Liu Kang and Kung Lao this is a nod
to the spin-off game of the same name
which was a co-op beat him up starring
the two characters but what really makes
us neat is the follow up chapter is
called fire in ice fire and ice was the
name of the cancelled sequel to Shaolin
monks which would have starred Scorpion
and sub-zero the two characters you play
as in the story chapter
your hearing is feeling sub-zero I
recognized your footsteps Hanzo thanks
for watching this video and please share
your favorite reference that you found
in the game in the comments below
[Music]
you